bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 6
janvier merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
comme chaque jour nous revenons sur
votre actualité locale entouré de nos
invités mais également des journalistes
de la rédaction tout de suite commençons
avec les titres de cette édition les
soldes débutent aujourd'hui une première
journée et déjà des fortes des marques
pour compenser des ventes en berne ces
derniers mois écoulés les stocks
importants des commerçants mercredi 6
janvier la date traditionnelle pour
tirer les rois pas définition galette
bien évidemment les boulangers se
prépare pour ce premier rendez vous
gourmand de l'année et enfin le logement
dans les yvelines et ses territoires
qu'elles sont des nouvelles dynamiques
et politiques mises en place pour 2016
caroline talbot directrice de l'adil 78
répond à nos questions et nous parle du
dit du logement pour aider les
particuliers et les voeux présentés par
les mères à leurs adhérents liste alors
administrée par dons continuent il hier
soir 7 et françois de ligne et maire de
guyancourt qui s'adressait aux habitants
de sa commune
une soirée pour dresser le bilan de
l'année 2015
à l'image de bertrand au lion maire
socialiste de magny les hameaux lundi
soir françois de villiers s'est lui
aussi montré incisif envers la nouvelle
communauté d'agglomération passer de
sept à douze connu le 1er janvier il
était hier soir au micro de mélanie
potier moment dit marc de
l'élargissement il ya une grande crainte
c'est celle de la confiscation
d'intercommunalité quand le président
annonce que les vice présidents et les
conseillers communautaires seront
seulement issus des villes de droite
c'est une confiscation
tout d'abord l'intériorité se doit
concerner l'ensemble des communes je
vois pas pourquoi
quatre communes serait mis à l'écart et
pourquoi les mères qui représentent
leurs habitants n'auraient plus voix au
chapitre
à partir du moment on n'a plus aucune
possibilité d'agir
ça veut dire que nos communes sont
écartés 2015 nous en avait donné les
prémices
rappelez-vous des débats à l'époque sur
la culture
et puis nous en parlions hier benoît
hamon doit quitter son poste de
conseiller municipal de train de trappes
en raison du non cumul des mandats après
son élection au conseil régional il ne
siègera pas non plus à l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines
ce qui ne l'empêchent pas de juger
sévèrement les choix de la majorité tout
comme françois de l'ine que l'on vient
d'entendre
écoutez donc à présent le numéro deux du
ps dans le département
on n'a jamais vu qu'on exclue et comme
cela les maires des villes d'exécutif
quand ça va être
l'anomalie faut que ça continue ça veut
dire que 4 visée pas les moins peuplées
ne seront pas représentés aux exécutifs
d'une agglomération tapas d'une ville
d'une agglomération effet totalement
contraire à l'esprit de la loi a lancé
permis par la loi et détruit la loi fait
pas peur et le lancement des soldes
d'hiver a été donné ce matin jusqu'au 16
février les commerçants s'apprête à
réaliser un maximum de ventes pour
pallier les mauvais chiffres d'affaires
des derniers mois due aux attentats
mais aussi au climat très doux au centre
commercial de parly 2 au chesnay
certains commerçants n'hésitent pas à
casser les prix dès le début de la
première démarque
william el est mary loisel étaient
présents des ouvertures des magasins
regarder 30 40 et parfois même 60% pour
cette première journée de soldes
certaines enseignes affichent déjà des
prix que l'on retrouve habituellement
deuxième ou troisième démarque comparé à
l'année précédente les ventes d'articles
de vêtements d'hiver ont chuté sur ces
deux derniers mois
conséquence d'une météo trop douce
d'habitude sur les produits des marques
et on commence avec 20% cette année on
n'a absolument rien à 20% mais on
commence à 30% et ça monte sur des
pièces à manches jusqu'à l'âge où dix
60%
dès l'entrée des soldes c'est jamais
arrivé le climat mais aussi les
attentats du 13 novembre ont freiné les
clients jusqu'à mi-décembre dans ce
grand centre commercial du chéné ou le
directeur attend 40 % de fréquentation
supplémentaire par rapport à une journée
classique la sécurité a elle aussi été
renforcée nous avons donc renforcé les
points stratégiques et les contrôleurs
rentrée avec un nombre supplémentaire
d'agents nous effectuons des fouilles
des inspections visuelles et effets
personnels des clients et nous sommes en
relation avec les autorités compétentes
pour ce dispositif du plan vigipirate
des stocks complet des articles bradés
avec beaucoup plus de tailles
disponibles qu'à l'habitude
les soldes c'est surtout le moment des
bonnes affaires j'ai très souvent sens
commercial
le premier jour des soldes est le
dernier s'éteint dans mes habitudes
voilà on fait notre petit tour pour
l'instant on a fait juste un achat
je n'ai pas d'objectif et ses ciels au
coup de coeur oreillettes flairer les
bons plans pour les clients mais aussi
pour les grandes enseignes plus onéreuse
c'est l'occasion de voir de nouveaux
clients comme cette boutique de
prêt-à-porter pour homme
c'est ce qui se passe en général au
niveau des sols les gens nous découvrent
aussi à ce moment là ou pas les gens
qu'on voit spécialement l'année qui
consomment pas spécialement
ils connaissent pas qui me découvre
assez de bonnes affaires pour tout le
monde d'après un sondage de la ls à 75%
des consommateurs ont l'intention de
faire les soldes
avec un budget moyen de 215 euros par
personne une baisse de 5% par rapport à
l'année précédente et à l'espace 50 ans
les soldes ont débuté timidement ce
matin à l'ouverture du centre à 8h30
mais l'affluence s'est accélérée et à 14
heures la majorité des commerçants
étaient sur leurs objectifs de vente
centre commercial espère faire mieux sur
cette campagne 2016 que l'année dernière
les soldes avaient été très impacté par
les attentats de janvier les précisions
du directeur du centre au micro de fanny
bourdillon l'année dernière forcément
avec eux ce qui s'était passé au mois de
janvier de l'année dernière la
fréquentation a été compliqué sur la
première semaine de soldes
ça a été difficile pour que ça se
remettre dans le bain contrairement à
cette année au mois de novembre
aujourd'hui le client attend toujours de
faire des bonnes affaires et evian dans
les magasins comme on a pu le voir au
sur la période de noël ou de fin d'année
où les clients étaient présents pour ce
rendez vous ça reste des rendez vous
importants au dos rencontre entre
commerçants les clients et c'est
également un incontournable de ce début
d'année la traditionnelle galette des
rois
les boulangeries s'organisent pour
satisfaire les gourmands la maison de
l'angle à versailles prévoit d'en vendre
une cinquantaine par jour pendant tout
le mois de janvier et revisite un peu la
recette habituelle
williams est les mairies loisel pour ce
reportage après noël et sa bûche place à
l'épiphanie il sa galette des rois un
moment important pour les gourmands et
surtout pour les artisans boulangers
afin de bien débuter l'année à
versailles cette boulangerie se prépare
à vendre environ 800 galettes sur le
mois à venir
c'est une période de fêtes comme pas
comme noël c'est des périodes fortes qui
nous permettent de faire un chiffre
d'affaires un peu plus important qu'une
journée classique quasiment tous nos
clients achètent une galette au moins
une pendant tout le mois de janvier
une organisation sans faille nécessaire
pour les fabriquer les cuire rapidement
le feuilletage a besoin de temps et de
repos différentes variétés sont ainsi
proposés un moyen de ravir les papilles
du plus grand nombre
où on fait la galette frangipane la
classique la galette aux pommes
la galette sèche et la galette bordelais
second coffret confié donc plus une
tradition du sud la galette se décline
pour tous les goûts parfois très
originaux c'est le cas de la galette
bordelaise faite de pâte briochée
agrémenté de fruits confits de noisette
et de pralines mais la grande favorite
reste la frangipane g20 c'est la
meilleure galette
tranchez panne tout simple la vraie
vraie galette c'est normalement et de la
frangipane ses traditionnels une
occasion également de tirer les rois et
les reines la fève est une tradition qui
elle ne change pas selon le site
agro-media ce sont près de 30 millions
de galettes que les français déguste
chaque année et nous recevons ce soir en
plateau caroline tamaynut directrice de
l'adil bonsoir à vous vous êtes
directrice de l' agence départementale
d'information sur le logement dans les
yvelines alors tout d'abord est ce que
vous pouvez re préciser un petit peu
l'émission de l'adie qui ne sont pas
forcément connus de tous
exactement on l'a dit c'est une jeune
structure associative qui a le format de
la loi de 1901 qui a été créée à
l'initiative du département des yvelines
de l'état avec pour objectif de
renseigner les particuliers yvelinois
sur toutes leurs problématiques d'accès
et de maintien au logement
donc c'est une équipe de dix juristes
qui intervient sur le siège de
versailles 19 permanence dans le
département alors justement vous venez
de sortir donc un document qui s'en dit
il s'intitule portrait du logement
évinois de ce territoire en 2016 alors
je les six la séquence huit appartements
qu'elles sont un peu les grandes
tendances pour 2016 demandant le
logement pour dans les yvelines
alors ce portrait du logement dans les
yvelines et ses territoires parce que
c'est la précision effectivement cette
année a pour objectif de donner à tout
un chacun un certain nombre
d'informations sur le parc de logements
sur le nombre de logements locatifs
sociaux
sa localisation sur la construction des
logements alors donné une grande
tendance 1 c'est effectivement un peu
difficile avec un 10 pas un département
aussi important que le nôtre
d'autant plus qu'on a des spécificités
par territoire qui se décide
mais on peut dire effectivement que le
département des yvelines est un
département extrêmement attractif du
point de vue du logement aussi bien
parce qu'il n'en produit que parce qu'il
il est très demandé par les locataires
comme par les propriétés et par exemple
sur un territoire aux précédents de
saint quentin en yvelines qui
concentrent quand même beaucoup
d'habitations qu'elles sont dits peu
voilà les spécificités est-ce qu'il ya
plus de locataires et de propriétaires
alors sur le territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines si on prend la configuration
depuis le 1er janvier 2016 c'est un
territoire très important puisqu'il
compose il est composé aujourd'hui de
230 mille habitants c'est le troisième
pôle d'emploi
quasiment en ile de france après paris
et la défense et donc c'est un
territoire qui jeunes et donc les
constructions qui sont produits sur le
logement était jeunes sont suffisamment
nombreuses pour répondre à la demande
des ménages d'autant puisque il me
semble qu'il ya une réelle politique à
une dynamique a été mise en place depuis
de nombreuses années sur ce territoire
qui permet à tout un panel de deux
personnes de pouvoir trouver de la
location dans le parc privé dans le parc
social mais aussi en accession à la
propriété
c'est un territoire qui est très
intéressant à analyser par rapport aux
autres
alors est ce qu'on peut savoir ce qu'on
peut dire ce qui est facile d'accéder à
par exemple à la propriété lorsqu'on est
il des noix de plus qu'ailleurs ou pas
forcément alors on peut accéder à la
propriété quand yvelinois l'offre elle
est présente que ce soit dans le neuf ou
dans l'ancien la seule problématique qui
peut se poser ce sont les prix d'accès à
ces logements
effectivement on est dans un territoire
attractif où on a des prix au mètre
carré qui s'envole sur certaines villes
et sur certaines communes
donc ça nécessite de la part des ménages
à revenus de l'enor des ouvriers avaient
tout à fait
donc que ce soit aussi dans la zone
rurale comme dans la zone urbaine on a
vraiment un département qui de ce point
de vue là et homogène après vous avez
des territoires qui ont des prix qui
sont un peu plus bas donc qui permet à
des ménages de pouvoir accéder
ce sont des communes notamment sur saint
quentin on va avoir des communes ont
produit énormément c'est trappe ça va
être fait ils encourent
mais c'est aussi mon tennis est aussi
guyancourt le seul risque dans notre
département c'est que les jeunes ménages
les jeunes et les jeunes ménages ainsi
mon pain suffit d'amener un revenu
suffisamment élevés peuvent être attirés
par un report de leurs achats sur les
franges ouest de notre département c'est
à dire dans l'eure et dans l'eure et
loir et justement leur 2016 qui va y
avoir du changement qui est lointain
type et les politiques nationales ou
locales de construction ou de
reconstruction dans les yvelines alors
en 2016 on doit parler de du prêt à taux
zéro qui est un prêt qui permet à des
jeunes ménages de pouvoir mobiliser ce
prêt en plus d'un prêt souscrit auprès
d'une banque pour se porter acquéreurs
d'un logement depuis trois années ce
prêt était essentiellement réservé à
l'achat des logements neufs ce qui
faisait qu'on avait tout un marché de
l'ancien qui n'était plus accessible à
ces primo accédants ce prêt depuis le
1er janvier couvre à nouveau le secteur
de l'ancien ces plafonds de ressources
pour pouvoir y accéder
on était augmentée permettant en plus de
ménages dits être éligible le montant du
prêt à taux zéro a été aussi augmentée
dont on peut penser effectivement qu'on
va voir revenir sur le marché de la
primo-accession un certain nombre de
ménages
donc ça son coin des nouvelles
encourageantes justement que l'ancien
reviennent est ce que au niveau des lois
par exemple je pense à la loi duflot est
ce que ça va impacter les locataires les
propriétaires en 2016 alors quand vous
parlez de la loi du flou est ce que vous
parlez de la loi allure qui
effectivement date de mars 2014 et qui a
mis en place un certain nombre de
mesures parmi lesquelles on peut citer
pour les locataires
le la mise en place par exemple d'une
garantie
des loyers qui s'appelait à l'époque la
garantie universelle des loyers mais qui
a été remplacé et qui sera désormais
remplacée par une aide accordée par le
1% logement
on peut aussi ajouter qu'on a un certain
nombre de législations qui ne concerne
pas directement les yvelines plutôt
paris qui porte sur l'encadrement des
loyers mais est ce que cette cette
mesure plus ou moins populaire sera
étendu au reste du département
ça on le verra effectivement avec les
nouvelles et les mauvais présidence de
région qui se sont mis notamment en
place au niveau et les religions sociaux
qui est une grosse problématique voilà
en ce moment dans notre actualité
les quotas entre guillemets sont
respectés dans les yvelines ou peut-être
sur saint quentin en yvelines
précisément pour le logement social à je
regarde un peu mes chiffres le parc de
logement social dans les yvelines de
façon générale est représentée par 115
mille logements c'est à peu près ces 21
% des résidences principales
la loi effectivement exige aujourd'hui
la loi allure qui a été la loi et le
enel pardon qui a été modifié demande
qu'on ait 21% 2 25% de logements
locatifs sociaux
ce chiffre globalement à l'échelle de
cinq enfants est respecté nous sommes à
31 % de logements locatifs sociaux même
si on a effectivement quelques communes
qui vont devoir aller sur ce qu'on
appelle un rattrapage sur des périodes
qui sont donc triennal tous les trois
ans et normalement c'est quelque chose
qui devrait se faire puisqu'on y dans un
1 1 une dynamique de production aussi
bien à l'échelle du département que de
l'agglomération qui tend vers ça y est
les aides spécifiques justement d'un
autre département pour les locataires ou
les propriétaires non pour les pour les
locataires et les propriétaires n'en
parce que sans les politiques souvent
qu'ils sont nationales locales elles
sont aidées indirectement pas par une
aide financière en cash
mais par exemple en concernant saint
quentin en yvelines
vous avez une politique de minoration
des prix donc de baisse des prix de
vente qui permet effectivement à des
ménages qui n'auraient pas pu le faire
de pouvoir accéder donc de ce sens là on
peut dire oui qu'il ya des politiques
effectivement qui sont mises en place
cette chine alors justement il ya
beaucoup de changements au niveau des
intercommunalités on voit que
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines va s'agrandir est-ce que cela
va impacter le logement va la voir des
politiques différentes c'est ce que les
locataires ou les propriétaires devront
agir différemment
rapport au logement dans ces conditions
vous avez raison effectivement sur les 1
million 400 mille habitants aujourd'hui
vont être regroupées sur ce qu'on
appelle 13 intercommunalités dont on a
quatre qui sont en zone urbaine et 6 qui
seront effectivement en zone rurale
est-ce que ça va impacter la politique
du logement oui forcément puisque les la
modification législative tendaient à
donner plus de compétences à
l'intercommunalité pour être en capacité
aujourd'hui de décider et de pouvoir
effectivement décidé dé construction en
lien avec la demande qu'il ya sur le
territoire dont on peut penser
effectivement que on aura des dynamiques
qui vont se dégager dans les territoires
et qui ne peuvent que servir l'intérêt
des devils alors vous avez justement a
sorti également un guide à destination
des particuliers pour les aider à se
retrouver à ceux ci retrouver un petit
peu car ça que pour accéder à la
propriété ce n'est pas forcément facile
pour tout le monde quel son emploi les
conseils qu'on peut y trouver
ajustements dans ce guide
alors le guide se loger dans les dents
les zivis et une deuxième édition
on a voulu répondre finalement à la
problématique de logements qu'on avait
pu constater dans le portrait en donnant
la possibilité à des professionnels mais
aussi à des particuliers d'avoir le
recensement de toute l'offre de
logements territoire par territoire
donc on peut trouver ici par exemple la
liste des lieux où on peut enregistrer
une demande de logement social
la liste des coordonnées des structures
qui peuvent vous hébergez puisqu'il faut
savoir que dans la problématique du
logement y a pas que le logement
perrin il ya aussi des personnes qui ont
la nécessité d'avoir un hébergement
d'urgence
le logement pour les seniors le logement
pour les qui sont adaptés au handicap
le logement pour des travailleurs
migrants donc on a essayé de recenser
territoire par territoire de manière à
permettre à tout un chacun effectivement
qui se retrouvera dans une problématique
dit trouver une réponse et une deuxième
partie qui elle concerne plus les petits
conseils on peut effectivement donner un
locataire lorsqu'ils recherchent un
logement
comment bien monter un dossier de
manière à ce qu'il puisse être accepté
par une une agence immobilière
et pour trouver plus facilement des
chemins notamment dans le parc dans le
parc privé alors sa guise dans leurs
trous il fallait vous consulté pour le
absolument pas c'est un guide qu'on peut
télécharger à partir de notre site
internet en 3 w à 10 78 point org ou
nous adresser un mail il est envoyé en
version essentiellement informatique et
on peut également venir vous voir pour
avoir à des conseils pratiques tout à
fait comme je l'indiquais on a dix neuf
permanence dans le département et en os
ça nous permet de recevoir quand même
11700 ménage tous les ans très bien
merci beaucoup d'être venu centre bateau
et d'avoir répondu à nos questions et le
1er janvier 2016 le plan anti gaspillage
alimentaire est entrée en vigueur la loi
sur les biodéchets oblige à présent les
restaurants les restaurants pardon
produisons plus de dix tonnes de déchets
par an à trier leurs déchets le 2 10
bagues cette formule qui permet de
proposer d'en porter à la fin de son
repas est également recommandée même si
elle n'est pas toujours obligatoire où
il ya mais les pâtres exacte et d'x men
ne vous étonnez plus si au restaurant
vous propose d'apporter la fin de votre
repas chez vous le doggy bag cette
formule bien connue des anglo saxons
peine à s'imposer en france depuis des
années même si certains établissements
ont toujours proposé
je pense que dès l'ouverture du bistrot
il ya vingt ans à chaque fois qu'un
client nous a demandé je peux emmener
sage pour mener ma bouteille je peux
emmener ce qui brille je n'avais pas
faim je vais faire on l'a toujours fait
on a toujours fait donc la loi ne change
pas grand chose pour nous aux tats-unis
le doggy bag est obligatoire depuis très
très longtemps et c'est dans les moeurs
de plus de tous les restaurants
donc c'est bien de commencer doucement
en france est conforme à la conduite que
tout un chacun devrait avoir avec la loi
sur les biodéchets les restaurateurs
effectuant plus de 150 couverts par jour
sont désormais obligés de trier leurs
déchets le doggy bag désormais
recommandé aux restaurateurs n'est pour
autant toujours pas obligatoire mais
aussi rarement sollicités par les
clients en réalité l'utilisation des
doggy bag
vous savez s'inscrit dans une génétique
sociétale or ce n'est pas la nôtre
donc nous nous avons bien entendu des
clientes qui elle est et soit dans leur
assiette on leur propose parfois nous
n'avons jamais eu un seul client
a accepté de ramener ça à la maison
voilà donc c'est pas dans notre futur
c'est aussi simple que ça il permet
pourtant d'éviter le gaspillage et de
rester dans une logique écologique le
doggy bag pas encore ancré dans notre
culture reste boudée par les français et
ce soir dans notre chronique nous
accueillons mélanie poté pour nous
parler environnement bonsoir mélanine
sanfloraine bonne année à vous en cette
période de bonnes résolutions pour rien
c'est une autre spectateur peut être
faire des écogestes vous le faites
peut-être déjà chez vous mais vous vont
également le faire au travail
nous sommes environ 13 millions
d'employés de bureau et d'administratifs
en france cela représente 46% de la
population active et la plupart d'entre
nous travaillent avec un ordinateur
c'est vrai c'est vrai parce que
l'ordinateur et l'appareil électrique
indispensable ou presque et on ne pense
pas souvent à l'éteindre 4% des écrans
et 15% des unités centrales sont laissés
allumés en permanence nuits et week-ends
compris
clément brandon la deûle agence locale
de l'énergie et du climat de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines donne quelques
conseils sur leur utilisation en conseil
c'est utiliser une multiprises avec
interrupteur pour voir la couper
complètement la nuit après bien utiliser
le mode veille ou éteint l'écran dès qu
on s'absente qu'on fait des petites
pauses ou qu'on n'utilise pas pareil
quand on est au téléphone pour les
équipements comme l'imprimante et le
photocopieur il est plus économe de
s'équiper d'un appareil multifonction et
le geste le plus économe l'économe c'est
de relier tous les ordinateurs à une
imprimante collective car ce sont des
éco gestes que l'on pourrait qualifier à
deux logiques et presque d'instinctif
mais ce que l'on sait moins c'est qu'une
bonne gestion des emails également est
un écogeste bonne gestion parce qu'il
faut savoir qu envoyer trente trois
courriels d'un mégaoctet à deux
destinataires par jour et par personne
génère annuellement 180 kg de co2 ça
équivaut à plus de mille kilomètres
parcourus en voiture et multiplier par
dix le nombre des destinataires ça
multiplie cette fois par quatre son
impact climatique et un dernier petit
exemple envoyer un courriel avec une
pièce jointe de pièces jointes de 1
mégaoctet consomme 7 5 kg équivalent de
faire pour faire plus simple c'est le
poids d'une pièce de 1 euro
on écoute à nouveau clément bon dont
l'un de l'alec il nous explique pourquoi
les mails sont énergivores
en fait ce qu'ils consomment c'est tout
ce qu'il
être les serveurs derrière pour l'envoi
et le stockage de ces emails ça aussi
c'est important tout ce qui est email
qui vont être stockés sur notre
ordinateur et sur ses serveurs vont
consommer de la place donc des matières
premières de l'espace qui est de
l'énergie pour les refroidir
alors ça c'est assez étonnant on sait
pas que les mails consomme autant
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour réduire
cet impact alors autant c'est important
ce n'est pas non plus le plus important
mais si vous voulez jouer sur les email
il faut cibler ses destinataires limiter
les envois en nombre
le choix des pièces jointes est aussi
très important on optimise au maximum la
taille des documents
on compterait ces fichiers ont fait la
basse résolution si vous en voyez des
images ou des pdf et si vos documents se
trouvent déjà sur internet au lieu de le
mettre dans les mails vous faites un
lien hypertexte dernier élément on peut
aussi gérer le stockage en supprimant
les e-mails l'indispensable alors il n'y
a pas que le mais il ya aussi
l'utilisation du papier selon l' agence
de l'environnement et de la maîtrise de
l'énergie
les français produisent chaque année 900
mille tonnes de déchets papier c'est
énorme c'est énorme c'est le premier
consommables utilisés au bureau le
papier c'est 65 kg consommés par an et
par personne
ça représente environ 25 ramettes de
papier et malheureusement on ne recycle
que 35%
alors cette fois encore les gestes sont
simples il faut éviter de tout imprimé
on peut configurer son imprimante en
mode recto verso s qui peut marcher
aussi c'est de faire deux pages par
feuille
autre élément parmi ces éco gestes il
faut pas oublier le chauffage puisque ça
représente quand même 50 % de la
consommation d'une entreprise le premier
geste à adopter c'est de baisser la
température
on le met on met le thermostat à 19
degrés ce qui est conseillé dans une
entreprise et l'éclairage quand on a
tous besoin
il faut savoir que si on oublie dix
minutes trois fois par jours d'éteindre
la lumière c'est plus courant que ce
qu'on pourrait penser à la fin de
l'année ça fait cinq jours d'éclairage
en continu je vous ai donné quelques
exemples floral
si vous voulez découvrir tous les éco
gestes ce qu'on en a beaucoup
une rubrique est accessible sur le site
de l'ademe c'est la rubrique
particuliers et écocitoyen florane il ne
vous reste plus qu'à vous lancer et le
téléspectateur à sensibiliser collègues
employeurs et employés
eh bien pourquoi pas ma ligne ça sera
peut-être ma bonne résolution de l'année
2016 ce que vous avez un sapin pour les
fêtes mais la nuit est offerte en mes
collègues vous avez de la chance que
vous allez leur cycle et peut-être ça va
vous donner des idées
les fêtes passées en fait le sapin
nouvelles restent souvent sur les bras
sans que je sache vraiment quoi en faire
plutôt que de le voir partir à la
poubelle
plusieurs communes sur saint quentin en
yvelines ont mis en place une opération
de recyclage des sapins seront ensuite
broyés et serviront de paillage
l'initiative pratique mais aussi
écologique
un reportage signé camille lambert et
miré loisel des enclos pour sapin
disséminés un peu partout dans voisins
le bretonneux
c'est l'opération de recyclage organisé
par la mairie des sapins ensuite
transformé en paillage pour protéger les
plantes de la commune
donc on va le mettre sur les massifs
soient des rebuts soit de terre de
bruyère pour empêcher en fait là un
repos ces mauvaises herbes et puis
maintenir un niveau d'hygrométrie
suffisant pour les plantes
il ya complètement une portée écologique
et développement durable dans cette
opération faty nous paraissait un peu
dommage de voir les sapins partir à la
poubelle
l'an dernier plus de 800 sapins de noël
ont été récoltés un succès qui a inspiré
d'autres villes alentour comme magny les
hameaux
pour la première fois des bennes sont
installées dans trois endroits de la
ville j'étais très bien je n'aurais pas
partout ils vont être traitées à la
commune
ils vont faire du compost c'est une très
bonne chose très bonne initiative
l'idée était dans l'air depuis plusieurs
années et là les personnels des services
techniques ont décidé de mettre en
oeuvre
cette année donc on se lance on va faire
l'essai on va voir éventuellement les
améliorations qui aura apporté pour les
années suivantes lémanique oie ont
encore vendredi 8 et lundi 11 janvier
pour déposer leur sapin les adresses des
bennes sont à retrouver sur le site de
la ville à voisins le bretonneux les
sept points de collecte reste à
disposition jusqu'au 17 janvier
on vous avait justement tout le mois de
janvier pour faire vos vais prendre vos
bonnes résolutions pour cette nouvelle
année 2016 alors quelles sont elles
quelles vont être vos voeux vos
résolutions c'est la question que nous
vous posons toute cette semaine
regardez vos réponses on arrête toutes
ces bêtises et que voilà un paix dans le
monde ça ça parait voilà puis résolution
arrêter de grignoter sépare l argent
voyage tout ce qu'on peut imaginer de
beaux et puis eh ben pour les
résolutions c'est d'y penser un peu
moins d'argent
la france on est sur une année un peu
plus calme presque avec un peu plus
d'emplois pour tout le monde mais
surtout du calme en fait pour la france
ce point de vue résolution c'est que bon
que ce chômage puisse
c'est inverser la courbe de taux -
puisse inverser devrait essayer
d'arrêter de fumer mais bon j'ai pas
c'est difficile
donc voilà ça a pu faire d'histoires
aussi j'aimerais essayer de remettre un
peu aux sports être heureux toute ma vie
ce qui me reste à vivre
à bientôt et bonne année à tous les
ennemis montrent un nous verrons l'année
prochaine si vous les avez tenu c'est la
fin de cette édition merci de nous avoir
suivis tout de suite vous avez rendez
vous avec sephora namani pour la
première édition de kiosques de l'année
votre magazine culturel quant à moi je
vous retrouve demain pour une nouvelle
édition du journal je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée